voyez là il ya trois pieds qui il ya
plus la graine dessus de trois pieds que
les corbeaux ont arraché sur les 40
hectares de maïs cultivée par cet
agriculteur une douzaine a été pillé par
les corneilles partout dans le loiret
d'autres exploitations subissent
l'assaut des volatiles ravageur alors
qu'aucun des dispositifs mis en place
pour les repousser et efficace tout a
été essayé mais en fait pas grand chose
fonctionne en acier d'enrobé les graines
avec du piment du tabasco ça fonctionne
pas il ya eu avant il y avait un
traitement de semences qui est qui a été
interdite qui fonctionnait et qui
fonctionnait bon temps que la granite et
dans le sol il y touchait pas après on a
essayé d ce qu'on appelle les bonnes
fort des effaroucheurs ce monde y
viennent au pied du lait farouche allié
des cerfs-volants seule solution
ressemer ici ce sont les cultures de
tournesol qui sont la proie des pigeons
et des corneilles j'ai essayé de semer à
25 centimètres durant donc avec les gps
aujourd'hui on est capable de le faire
donc ça a permis potentiellement de
sauver ce qui était déjà en place
une heure après qu'on ait ressemer
finalement il y avait
il y avait une trentaine de corbeaux qui
était déjà dans le champ en train de
train de commencer à gratter quoi la
corneille est une véritable calamité et
pour les agriculteurs la perte est sèche
puisqu'elle ne leur donne droit à aucune
indemnité
donc là on espère typiquement que il
annonce bien 20 degrés samedi prochain
pour que finalement ça plus vite et que
ça se fasse pas manger une deuxième fois
quand la profession réclame aussi la
régulation de l'espèce à des couvertures
de battues administratives
à l'instar de celles organisées contre
l'autre grand prédateur des cultures le
sanglier